[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers not one
winner we've never made a mistake phew
there goes another one hell was that
that wasn't someone trying to criticize
it okay
well tonight I've never seen that before
sorry he entered my cash desk sorry
that's what I did wipe it up with a
flash here come into my camera one more
time
well anyway we've got a great show it
sorry mr. O'Brien yeah I Spit again yeah
speak comes out when I do that you
better get it out before Bill Hader
comes
well guess what I think it's fan
correction yeah I don't know what we're
doing it's fan correction right and
someone said yeah they trying to catch
us right well tonight a fan named rien
believes she's caught a mistake she says
it happened when I recently did an
impression of Popeye on the show hi
Conan I'm pretty sure I found an error
on your episode on June 26th you're
talking about the interview that Matt
Lauer did with Paula Deen and then the
interview Paula comment and I is what is
during an interview on The Today Show
Paula Deen started crying and said I is
what I is so proudly Dean's not racist
she's Popeye I need to correct you come
in because pop I never said is what is
pop I only said I am what I am what I am
so I think I've got you toning
well Rhian very nice try but I'm sorry
you are completely wrong
pop I did say I is what I is the clip
you showed was from 1933 I was referring
to the 1932 Popeye which was before
Popeye had completed his formal
education to prove it take a look at
this exclusive Popeye cartoon from 1932
[Laughter]
don't worry sweetie I is what is she's
right it should be I am what I am
I knows I'm just not educated but you'll
see I'll go back to school and get me
GED and by 1933 I'll be using the goods
grammar I graduated from Princeton well
then you deserve this
[Music]
I've never know Bruno went to Princeton
anyway the Chopin still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at Tim koco.com slash ha
ha I found an error we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro